this is a photo of the SCF primoria
tanker at the Port of Marcus Hook
Pennsylvania the ship used to frequent
American and European ports but recently
the 84 000 ton vessel has been sparred
off the coast of India after traveling
there from Russia according to ship
tracking data India used to buy almost
no Russian oil simply because of the
long distance from Russia's Sea ports to
India that changed after moscow's
invasion of Ukraine in February we're
Banning All Imports of Russian Oil and
Gas and energy after the West announced
sanctions an unprecedented amount of
Russian oil has been heading to China
India and other countries that have
ramped up purchases at a discounted
price for Russia that means more Revenue
than ever before as much as 20 billion
dollars in average monthly oil sales
this year compared to 14.6 billion
dollars last year so here's how Russia's
economy is getting help from oil trade
with China and India
before the war the European Union was
the largest consumer of Russian crude
spending the equivalent of more than 48
billion dollars on it last year a ban on
almost 90 percent of all Russian oil
imports by the end of the year as the EU
scales down purchases other countries
have negotiated deals to buy from Russia
this map shows some routes that Russian
oil travels on board tankers like the
SCF primordier to the Middle East and
Asia because of the reluctance of the EU
and other buyers to take Russian oil is
selling at a discount Laurie milibita is
a lead analyst of the finland-based
center for research on energy and clean
air the organization has been tracking
Russian oil shipments since the invasion
you can get a barrel of Russian oil at
about 30 percent less than than other
type of oil and that's a big incentive
to switch to using Russian oil when
that's possible
for example China which had already been
the largest single buyer of Russia's
crew before the war has ramped up
Imports in August China bought over 1
million barrels a day almost doubling
what it bought in February
while Beijing didn't openly support
Moscow and its invasion of Ukraine and
commodity Watchers say China is mostly
buying the soil because of its low price
this Business Partnership has become
very important for the Kremlin
and India has also become a huge market
for Russia in June it had increased
Imports of Russian oil by more than 25
folds since the start of the war and
those Imports were carried by tankers
like this one in this satellite image
captured off the coast of India as a an
alternative fire India has been
significant it's the largest single
increase in uh imports from Russia since
the start of the war
the demand from China and India along
with high oil prices have boosted
Russia's energy sales even if it exports
slightly less oil overall
but it doesn't mean Moscow no longer
needs the West Europe still buys more
than 50 percent of Russia's energy
resources and new sanctions could
further threaten those sales in
September the G7 agreed to impose a
price cap on Russian oil the plan would
ban Russian crude shipments from getting
services like insurance from G7
countries if the oil is sold over a
certain price and since more than half
of the vessels that carry Russian oil
are owned by EU companies analysts say
such a price cap could reduce the cash
flow from Moscow Russian oil imports is
still completely reliant on the use of
the European capacity to move oil
and if Europe really ends up imposing a
full ban on Russian oil imports like it
has proposed higher demand in Asia is
unlikely to compensate for the loss of
Russia's biggest export Market China is
already buying everything more or less
that Russia can ship to the Pacific
Market and India is buying less than 10
of of the oil in total so still dwarfed
by Europe still the strong demand for
Russia's oil by some of the world's
biggest economies has the potential to
take the sting out of Western sanctions
and unless stronger measures are taken
this might mean more long-distance
Journeys for the SCF premorier